I'm Jason E Street a penetration tester
and I'm here today to answer your
questions from the internet this is pin
testing support
[Music]
first up John Hannan hey Siri what is
penetration testing penetration testing
is basically a company hiring a hacker
or security professional to test their
security by breaking in via the website
or the building itself or you know their
internal network devices just any way
they can to validate their security at
volkis AU what's the most underrated
physical pin test tool you use a lot I
got a lot of them it's hard to narrow it
down to just one one of the things that
you you want to get when you're doing a
physical pin test is you want to record
as much data as you can I just need my
glasses that has a camera installed in
it with a Micro SD card to store the
data I have the newer version of the
Microsoft employee badge but quite
frankly why mess with a good thing no
one knows what the new employee badge
looks like anyway so I'm still using
this one mostly every engagement I go to
I'm always carrying a cup of coffee or a
clipboard because that way the camera is
facing the right way when I'm recording
it with my watch and I have at least one
or two video recorder pins that I carry
with me this is actually what the video
camera looks like this will if I get
close enough it will copy the employee
badge of employee going through the door
I can clone it and then I can resend
that to the gate or the door and it'll
let me in thinking I'm that employee
this looks like a typical iPhone charger
that's a micro computer with Wi-Fi and
Bluetooth with several different
payloads installed on it that I can
launch individually from my phone a lot
of CEOs a lot of Executives have those
high-end HDMI monitors that's perfect
because this screen crab plugs in HDMI
from the monitor into here then back to
the computer through here and Records it
onto a Micro SD card and also will
wirelessly transmit it to you so you're
seeing their whole desktop when I'm
feeling really fancy I like to wear my
cuff links because this comf link is a
USB wireless adapter turning any desktop
or any device or any server into its own
wireless access point into this
company's Network and then this one has
the drivers and malware that I I can
read and copy over onto that drive and
use it to launch the attacks with
stylish and also scary more ocean Sun
can you walk me through the process of a
penetration test including the different
phases and types of tests that may be
performed ninety percent of what you're
going to be doing on a penetration test
is Recon reconnaissance is actually
finding out all you can about the target
all the different variables checking
their websites trying to look to see
what technology they have looking at
their location see if you can find
blueprints online seeing if you can see
pictures from social media of what the
directions of the flows or what people
are doing what their security looks like
then with the scanning what you're doing
is usually doing different kinds of
scans to see what kind of Port responds
which will give you a better way of
trying to exploit it to see if there's
vulnerabilities in it then you're going
to try to see what you can compromise
and what kind of privileges you can
escalate or how you can pivot to other
parts of the network that can give you
more privilege and then you do the
exploitation phase where you're actually
running the code and trying to download
the data and then you export trait try
to get all that data out try to show
that it can be successfully taken away
from the client then the worst part of
the penetration test report is the
reporting because the report writing is
you know the boringest and the most
important part of the whole engagement
at Bella pada Anna can someone teach me
how to rob a bank from my phone yes and
no I'm not going to at dude who code
what's a hacker attire everybody thinks
it wants to be a hoodie I am way more
scarier when I'm dressed up in my suit
the whole stereotypes are what's going
to get you in trouble because when
they're not dressed like that stereotype
you're more likely to trust that person
or that attacker Acorn back what
documentation should you carry on site
for a physical pin test a get out of
jail free card in a get out of jail free
card is going to be the letter of
Engagement that the client gives you so
when someone catches you you show it to
them and it says hey they're supposed to
be here call me if you've got problems I
create a forged one that says yes I'm
supposed to be here and do these things
you're supposed supposed to help me and
not report it and hear some phone
numbers of the people to call but those
numbers actually goes to my teammates
who will then impersonate the voice of
the person that gave me the
authorization I can show you a video of
when I was conducting a physical pin
test on a bank here you can see me going
in and compromising the first machine
within 15 seconds awesome then you see
the manager I'm just here to do the USB
audit so I need to look at your computer
real quick okay actually escorting me
into the data server to leave me
unattended into their vault appreciate
your help thank you very much y'all take
care I gave them no documentation no
validation all it took was a forged
Microsoft employee badge to get me all
this access
10 million if you don't say I'm in are
you really a hacker no and you've got to
say it properly I'm in at tooth and Claw
uh TV what do you think is on this USB
drive that I found on my gate I always
assume Kitty pictures but I'll never
know because as I never plug in devices
that I find this isn't an episode of Mr
Robot I'm not going to go plug in stuff
that I find lying around but you should
be worried about this because yes that
is a valid tactic I will leave USB
drives in company bathrooms in lobby
bathrooms and more importantly when I'm
on an engagement I have a stack of blank
envelopes when I see someone that's not
at their desk or in their office but I
see their nameplate I write their name
on the empty envelope I put a malicious
USB drive in it I leave it on their desk
99.9 success rate because who's not
going to open up a sealed envelope in a
secured area that they're in and not
plug that into their computer at hide
and seek my fellow physical pin testers
what are some of your go-to resources
for doing ocean to gather info about
security measures your targets have in
place which do you think are underrated
I'll start Instagram is an absolute Gold
Mine osent means open source
intelligence trying to gather
information on companies using open
information like social media like
Google I am not going to argue with that
I totally agree I love Instagram if you
want to know why Security Professionals
drink go to Instagram and type in a
search hashtag new badge or hashtag new
job it's depressing if you have
employees showing their employee badges
sometimes in secured locations they're
taking pictures that they shouldn't take
but I will tell you this one that's
underrated going to LinkedIn looking at
the employees and the IT security
department and what you see is
everybody's listing their skills they
are telling you what they were hired for
so that means that's what the company is
working with and there's no alerts
that's going to go off on the company
that you're doing it at 5m477 good Recon
skills the most important key to being a
good penetration tester agreed what are
the tools you use for Recon main tool
that I use to be honest Google Google is
one of the best hacking tools ever
invented as soon as you list the company
in the Google search it's going to tell
you who the CEO is What their
subsidiaries are what are their similar
companies they give you all their social
video profiles nicely listed shows you
the geographical location of their main
headquarters building also might show
you how many employees they have gives
you the direct link to their website and
then when you start adding different
keywords like problem with your target
or Target vulnerabilities or Target
harassment which is called Google
Dorking you get way more information
than probably the company even wants you
to have about them and then going to
LinkedIn and finding their employees
finding their job postings which list
the different technologies that they
have employers will actually post nice
events that they've had with their
employees and the employees are wearing
their company badges so you can copy
that I robbed a telecom company in
another country once and by Rob I mean
simulating a what an actual criminal
will do the CEO of the company had went
to a conference three months before and
I went to that conference page found a
speaker that was in the same business as
him and then I assume that guy's
identity and I sent an email to the CEO
saying hey like we discussed three
months ago at this conference we would
like you to be on the board of directors
for our new initiative that we're having
here's the link to our website within 12
hours the CEO clicked the link he was
the one who hired me to do the
spearfishing attack and he still got
caught at gossy 84 a fiery debate and
cyber security is Red Team Versus Blue
Team which is better for those who don't
know red team usually means the
offensive security the people testing
the security the penetration testers
blue team is the defensive team working
for the company to protect their company
in their assets as a person who does a
lot of red teaming I will tell you this
the red team only exists to make the
blue team better so the blue team is the
one doing the hard work they're the ones
trying to build the defenses to keep
criminals out red teams are there just
to help them do their job better from be
healthy by NATO how do I know if my home
Wi-Fi is being hacked very simple you go
to the web interface for your router and
then there's going to be a field where
it says devices connected if it's got a
name that you've never seen before or
too many devices you know something's up
at zeph X2 two do you get hacked just by
clicking the link somebody sent yes not
only that but there have been certain
vulnerabilities and Office Products
where just having the reading pane open
would attack your machine just receiving
an SMS message or iMessage on an Apple
phone would compromise your machine so
yes it is just that simple at Josh
Savage web it legal question is it legal
to try and hack a website as part of
penetration testing without the owner
knowing no the main difference between
criminal activity and hacking is
permission if you may have been hide by
the client to do certain things in that
scope of work it has to say that the
website owner or the hosting has given
permission to also test that asset app
Mic Mac 29 what do hackers actually do
with your data they bundle it up and
they sell it in bulk your data is not
worth that much by itself and what they
can do with that information is not just
open up lines of credit they can tried
to go get passports they can try to get
identities they can try to create and
assume your identity and then sell these
to criminals at RZ cyber phishing
attacks why is email still such an easy
target for hackers my hot take because
companies are too busy investing in
technology instead of investing in their
employees if they invested more time and
money in educating their employees on
what kind of attacks are going on and
how they're part of the security team
from day one you would have a lot less
successful phishing attacks phishing
attacks are becoming more and more
prevalent 82 percent of attacks are
started with the phishing email over 30
billion dollars has been lost because of
these kind of phishing attacks at
Classic brand what do movies frequently
get wrong about hacking because of the
very essence of what hacking is
it's boring when you talk about straight
up computer network hacking it's bunch
of command prompts and it's just looking
at a screen as it does letters and
executing commands and then downloading
a file that's not exciting the reason
why hackers which was a great movie War
games which was a great movie they
visualized how the breaches were
happening they visualized how the hacks
were going because no one wants just to
see a bunch of lines and a bunch of code
dreaming around on a screen curb bill
you what does a firewall do you ever
been to a club that's like been very
exclusive and they're like no you can't
come in that's a firewall a firewall
inspects package going into the network
and it dictates it's like based on a
certain set of rules that have been set
by the client to allow packets in or not
and only in certain use cases that was
all the questions I'm hoping you learned
something and until next time
[Music]